[Música]
ah
como se imaginarán por mi forma de
hablar no soy de acá de costa rica vengo
desde uruguay uruguay no es un país
particularmente conocido a nivel mundial
seguro acá nos conoce muy bien pero
cuando viajamos por el mundo muchas
veces nos dicen qué lindo es paraguay y
tenemos que sonreír para mejor hablamos
muy parecidos a nuestros hermanos
argentinos y ahí también volvemos a
aclarar no no no venimos de un país
chiquito que está entre argentina y
brasil que se llama uruguay sin petróleo
sin acá natural hace un siglo que
uruguay se distingue por dos grandes
exportaciones las vacas y los jugadores
de fútbol si bien suárez cavani y forlán
son los nombres que suenan más en el
contexto internacional las vacas son las
que nos dan de comer y además hacen
ingresar muchas divisas al país
uruguay es un país que tradicionalmente
se mueve al ritmo del campo lo que pueda
exportar entra dando el siglo 21 con la
llegada
realización muchos dieron por perdido al
animalito en la época la economía
digital y las mega empresas muchos
pensaron que el paso cansino de la vaca
las iba a dejar atrás sin embargo por
allá por el año 2003 un grupo de
visionarios se dio cuenta de que al
igual que la música o las películas la
producción agropecuaria se podía también
digitalizar uruguay entonces se embarcó
en una misión inaudita había que
digitalizar a la vaca el ministerio de
ganadería convenció a más de 60 mil
productores de que la hazaña valía la
pena y los productores no sólo aceptaron
la propuesta sino que aceptaron la
apuesta no era obligatorio era
voluntario y como se digitaliza una vaca
y el primero hay que darle un número o
mejor dicho un chip con un número
además de llamarse clotilde o blanquita
cada vaca del uruguay comenzó a tener un
número que llevaba puesto en una
caravana en su oreja pero para
digitalizar una vaca no basta con una
caravana tradicional amarilla en la
oreja derecha se le colocó otra con un
chip en la izquierda hubo que
digitalizar los campos hubo que
digitalizar el camión que trasladaba a
blanquita y a clotilde y además tuvo que
digitalizar a los veterinarios que
atendían a las vacas los puntos de
pesaje las ferias ganaderas y las
plantas de faena hasta hay algunas
labores policiales que se transformaron
los policías rurales cuentan con una
aplicación que les permite saber de
quién es esa vaca y donde debería estar
esa vaca en ese momento al final uruguay
pasó de ceros a unos a cada vaca más de
12 millones de cabezas de ganado cuatro
veces la población del país
muchos en ese momento no veían los
beneficios para nosotros los carnívoros
lo que más importa en una vaca es poder
hacer una linda barbacoa con la familia
como se dice en esta zona en uruguay un
buen asado con amigos nadie va a la
tienda diciendo carnicero me da un
costillar que termina en park sin
embargo las fuerzas del mercado hoy no
sólo se ocupan del precio y la calidad
sino que los hábitos de consumo también
incluyen la trazabilidad de lo que se
quiere comprar pero no solo para los
alimentos en los mercado más exigente
quieren saber de dónde procede tal
producto en particular de dónde procede
esa pedazo de carne con que se alimentó
la vaca y con qué medicamento se curó
y digitalizando a la vaca uruguay no
sólo consiguió llevar las mejores carnes
a los mercados más estrictos sino
también obtener mejores precios por ello
por otra parte algunos países están
solicitando a los productores de carne
que demuestren que la cantidad de gases
de efecto invernadero que se producen
por la actividad ganadera sean
absorbidos en el propio país y uruguay
es el único país del mundo que lo puede
hacer gracias a este ecosistema digital
que construyó ya que tienen dónde está
el ganado exactamente y sabe dónde y
cuándo y cuánto hay de plantaciones
forestales y producción agrícola que
absorbe ese co2 que supuestamente es
producido por la actividad ganadera
hasta aquí en uruguay aprendimos tres
cosas la primera es que si puedo
digitalizar lo puedo vender lo mejor la
segunda todo lo que se digitaliza no
vuelve para atrás a nadie se le ocurre
volver al sistema que teníamos antes de
2003 a nadie se le ocurre que si probó
y comer durante la pandemia disfruto de
sus beneficios vuelva para atrás la
tercera una buena digitalización no es
un hecho aislado necesita un ecosistema
digital para perdurar
amazon necesito crear y apoyar un
sistema con distribución con logística
con colaboración de aplicaciones con
creadores y productores con empresas que
habilitarán los pagos digitales en china
además hay una empresa que se llama
haier que tiene 80.000 empleados pero en
realidad -ha ya la componen 4.000
empresas si hacemos la cuenta nos da de
promedio por empresa del orden de 20
empleados literalmente son pequeñas
empresas que trabajan como un ecosistema
y utilizando herramientas digitales
autogestión en un negocio de más de 10
mil millones de dólares
empresas como la china haier la
argentina mercadolibre la uruguaya ha
pedido ya la colombiana rápida entre
otras
vieron que trabajar en plataformas
digitales era el camino al crecimiento
el cual hoy es el camino a la
recuperación económica de todas las
industrias
algunas empresas podrán recuperarse de
forma analógica sin estar totalmente
digitalizadas o plataformas hadas pero
si sus competidores lo hacen perderán
competitividad y hasta podrán
desaparecer en cada ola evolutiva están
los visionarios los excesos de la vida
que vieron lo que estaba a punto de
pasar luego están las personas que saben
que la tecnología está madura y deciden
no quedarse atrás
y finalmente está el grupo kodak en el
que nadie quiere estar los que vieron
pasar la oportunidad y no quisieron o no
pudieron actuar digitalizarse implica
que tu mercado es el mundo que se crean
nuevos puestos de trabajo nuevas
profesiones nuevas áreas para exportar
digitalizarse implica que no sólo
vendemos logística servicios financieros
o pan
digitalizando nos vendemos información
certeza e inmediatez en un mundo sin
paciencia como dice el futurista español
javi creus cuando tu negocio lo
transformas en ceros y unos puedes
crecer de forma exponencial y aquellos
que le hicieron antes de la pandemia
crecieron aún más por lo tanto ahora que
sabemos que hasta una vaca se puede ver
como ceros y unos la pregunta que queda
es muy sencilla como tú te vas a
digitalizar países pequeños y bien
conectados como uruguay y costa rica
está en una posición privilegiada para
poder avanzar pero debemos comprender la
oportunidad que tenemos por delante y
aprender de los que se quedaron atrás
debemos crear ecosistemas
infraestructura y educación de calidad
he tenido la oportunidad de apoyar a dos
ecosistemas uno en el sector financiero
y otro en el sector de la salud en donde
he visto cómo crecen de forma
exponencial por estar digitalizados
además estos ecosistemas crecen más
rápido cuando son orquestados como
decimos nosotros o en otras palabras
coordinados por un actor relevante de la
economía real
para finalizar dije tengo una idea
fantástica genial si además de nuestras
vacas pudiéramos digitalizar a nuestros
jugadores de fútbol me ponía a trabajar
ya creo luego me di cuenta de que eso ya
lo había hecho la empresa de videojuegos
y esports y el resultado es el fifa que
hoy juegan mis hijos en su consola pura
vida
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah